ON
>> Mark: PAYNE GETS INTOISHLLY
GIANNIS THE SCREENER.
>> Ryan: WINNING.
THEY ARE FINDING W WTHREE,
AND CAN'T.
IT'S A TWO-POINT ON THE
THREE.
LOOKED LIKE HE RULE.
SO GIANNIS AND TO GO AND
PLAY. THREE AND THE MAVERICKS W
FINNEY-SMITH,  HOW ABOUT THE --
WE KEEP PACE JAYSON
TATUM, MAYBE 12 TO 15
BROWN WAS FINALS LAST
YEAR.
WHAT A PLAY AND THEN GIANNIS
FORTUNATELY FOR MILWAUKEE ON THE
LINE WITH A GUY WHO KHRIS MIDDL?
WE'LL SEE.
COULD CAM JOHNSON BE BACK THIS
WEEK?
JOKIC ONE ON ONE A A
7 SECONDS.
JOKIC HAS IT.
TURN REMAINING.
JOKIC STOLE THE[ BUZZER ]
>> TOUGH SHOT.
IN AND OUT. PLAY IN OVERTIME.
MO TO DO IT! LeBRON JAMES.
BUT GORDON WILL BE ON THE
ROCKETS SECOND TIME THAT
THE LAKERS WON OUT BUT THIS
DEFLECTION, CALDWELL-POPE
RECOVERS THE THREE.ON!
FADE AWAY THREE.
AIR BALL.
COFFEYILL DO IT.
THE FREE THROWS ARE GOOD.
AND THE CLIPPERSA
FOUL.BUT IT INS
NO TI
CALLING THE DEFENSIVE SIGNAL,
DETROIT IN NO HURRY, CUNNINGHAM
WILL DRIVE, TOOK IT LIKE
IT AGAINST BAGLEY GETS IT BACK
FROM THE SIDELINE, NO GOOD